si una vez más una resolución no sale
adelante por el veto de Rusia que como
saben es miembro permanente del Consejo
de Seguridad y tiene este derecho la
resolución ha contado con el apoyo de 10
países y uno en contra que es
precisamente la federación rusa y cuatro
ascensiones India gabón China y Brasil
se trata de una resolución presentada
por Estados Unidos y por Albania que
condenaba esos referéndums denunciados
internacionalmente que se han celebrado
en esas regiones ucranianas para
anexionar cuatro territorios a Rusia la
representante de Estados Unidos asegura
que se trata de una farsa que se ha
realizado a punta de cañón de pistolas
rusas y le pide a Rusia que revierta su
decisión y que saque inmediatamente las
tropas militares de suelo ucraniano por
su parte la federación rusa responde que
Estados Unidos y Albania presentando
esta resolución lo que están haciendo
provocar una provocación de bajo grado
según la federación rusa estas estas
votaciones han contado con estos
referendos ha contado con el apoyo de
los habitantes de estas cuatro regiones
ucranianas y además dice que cuentan
también con el apoyo de los
organizadores de Los observadores
Internacionales esta resolución pasará
ahora a la asamblea general de las
Naciones Unidas y allí no hay ya derecho
a